hauntings burials and the battle from
hell sometimes TV frightens actors more
than the audience
as all of the murder war and
manipulation comes to a head toward the
end of the eighth season run of HBO's
Epic Fantasy Game of Thrones the
contestants for The Iron Throne become
ever more vicious in their play for
power the second to last episode of
season six the battle of the bastards
depicts a bloody pivotal battle for
Winterfell fought by the armies of
would-be King in the north Jon Snow and
the cool upstart Ramsay Bolton you're
going to die tomorrow Lord Bolton
sleep well filming that elaborate
ambitious battle required 25 shooting
days 500 extras 600 crew members and 70
horses this means that pretty much
everything that is depicted on the
screen was very real much to the terror
of the actor who portrayed Jon Snow kit
Harrington at one point in the episode a
horde of enemy soldiers Moves In For the
Kill and it wasn't done with CGI there
really was a large group of men running
straight at into and on top of
Harrington he's buried under bodies at
one point all of which was a bit too
much for the actor he later told the
Belfast Telegraph I've got a few fears
spiders being one of them but the worst
is my claustrophobia I'm mortally afraid
of crowds I panic it was one of the most
terrifying things and most uncomfortable
debuting on the CW in January 2017. the
very first sequence in the very first
episode of Riverdale makes it clear that
the show will play out much differently
to the old-fashioned Archie Comics upon
which it's based after some ominous
establishing shots of the titular City
the action switches to the banks of the
Sweetwater River where identical twins
Jason and Cheryl Blossom board a small
boat and head out on the water a journey
that will leave Jason dead and his
sister traumatized even shooting that
scene was tough for Madeleine patch who
was a pronounced phobia of deep large
bodies of water she later told glamor I
assumed they'd used a stunt double in
the boat when I got to set they were
like so we're gonna put you in a wetsuit
it didn't help that co-star Trevor
Steins was in charge of operating the
boat something he'd never done before
patch said I was having a panic attack
no one knew I was freaking out I was
terrified of stepping in the boat but
then I got in and Trevor was amazing it
was great therapy but I was still
terrified
like many people Gabourey Sidibe prefers
her ghost to remain as little more than
special effects but a supernatural
experience made her think a real Spirit
showed up for one scene in American
Horror Story coven in episode 12
sidibe's character Queenie recites a
Latin spell to conjure an audience with
Papa legba a gatekeeper to the spirit
world during an evening with the women
of American Horror Story Sidibe said
that as she spoke the words the light
fixture above her started to shake and
she felt like she couldn't move while
shooting another part of the scene the
light picture crashed to the floor and
she felt a finger running up her chin to
her bottom lip which started to swell
City Bay and a makeup artist went to a
trailer to wait for Medical Treatments
and suddenly began to hear scratching
noises on the walls outside they only
stopped when a makeup artist said a
prayer and clapped her hands perhaps
understandably Sidibe refused to say the
Latin summoning words again but she
relented for the final episode when the
other actors struggled to get the hang
of them this time her top lips swelled
up as she herself said do not do this at
home you guys
the relationship between Vampire killer
Buffy Summers and the Ageless vicious
vampire Spike and Buffy the Vampire
Slayer was all kinds of complicated he
wanted to kill her she wanted to kill
him and then he became an undead living
experiment with an implant that removed
his desire to kill you know the usual
Boy Meets Girl stuff but somewhere early
on in the season 6 episode scene read
Spike was still an evil monster who was
quite willing to commit unspeakable acts
according to spike actor James Marsters
Creator Joss Whedon urged The Buffy
Riders to take their worst and darkest
real-life memories and put them into
scripts seeing red was informed by a
staff writer's recollection of trying to
win back an ax by forcing them into a
sexual encounter so the script called
for a desperate Spike to try that with
Buffy Marsters told the AV club it was
the hardest day of my professional life
I was curled up in a fetal position in
between takes I can't watch scenes like
that it was just unbelievably hard but
again I'm glad we did it Spike was evil
and I think a lot of people forgot about
that
in 1979 the second ever adaptation of a
Stephen King book hit screens a Salem's
Lot miniseries based on the author's
story about a small town ravaged by
vampires directed by Toby Hooper the
Salem's Lot limited series featured one
of the scariest and thus most indelible
TV moments of the time young Ralphie
Glick transformed into a pale-faced
monstrous vampire floats outside the
bedroom window of his brother Danny and
scratches at the glass imploring him to
let him in the look and Ron tribner's
eyes came not from an actor trying to
best convey his character but some
rather extreme discomfort he later told
Vanity Fair it was probably the pain
from the contact lenses digging into my
eyeballs Danny ultimately doesn't
survive his brother's vampirism and this
led to Brad Savage having to film a
graveyard scene as an undead boy
apparently dead Danny hangs out in the
coffin until he can drink the blood of
the local Gravedigger Savage later said
honestly out of my whole childhood
career that was the creepiest experience
they literally put me in a coffin and
lowered me down 8-10 feet into a hole
that was probably the most damage done
to my psyche foreign
[Music]